Das ist echt nichts für schwache Nerven:
Die Guinea-Würmer wandern an Muskeln und
Knochen vorbei und graben sich dann durch
die menschliche Haut an den Füßen, um im
Wasser ihre Larven abzulegen.
Man kann den Wurm nur mit der Hand entfernen
- und zwar, in dem man ihn auf einem Stöckchen
aufrollt - Stück für Stück.
Eine äußerst schmerzhafte Infektion, gegen
die es weder Impfung noch Medikamente gibt.
Doch jetzt könnten wir es tatsächlich schaffen,
den Erreger bald auszurotten.
Bisher ist uns das einzig und allein mit dem
Pockenvirus gelungen.
Ihr habt Euch dieses Thema bei Whats App gewünscht
und bekommt jetzt alle spannenden Facts rund
um den bösen Guineawurm und die große Ausrottungs-Kampagne!
Herzlich Willkommen bei Clixoom Science & Fiction!
Die Infektion mit “Draculus medinensis”,
so der wissenschaftliche Name des Guinea-Wurms,
braucht uns Menschen zum Überleben - als
Wirt also.
Sie wird in Nigeria “Armut” und in Mali
die “Krankheit der leeren Kornkammern genannt”.
Denn die infizierten Menschen sind so geschwächt,
dass sie nicht mehr arbeiten können, um ihr
Geld zu verdienen.
Die Infektionen sind nicht tödlich, doch
sehr schmerzhaft.
Und sie passieren durch ungefiltertes Trinkwasser.
Denn die Wurmlarven befallen winzige Krebse,
die im Wasser schwimmen.
Die Krebse sterben, doch die Parasitenlarven
haben ihr Ziel erreicht.
Sie wandern vom Magen aus in den Darm, durchdringen
die Schleimhaut und paaren sich.
Das Männchen stirbt kurz darauf; das Weibchen
dagegen wandert zu den Extremitäten - meistens
zu den Füßen.
Bis dahin wächst es auf eine Länge von bis
zu einem Meter und legt dann dort seine Larven
ab.
Ungefähr ein Jahr nach der Infektion beginnen
die Würmer, sich durch die Haut der Betroffenen
zu bohren, meistens im Bereich der Füße
und Beine.
Und zwar über Wochen hinweg!
Beim Durchstoßen der Haut empfindet der Wirt
große Schmerzen und so halten die Betroffenen
ihre Gliedmaßen ins kalte Wasser von Seen
und Füßen.
Das Weibchen platzt schließlich auf, setzt
Hunderte von Larven frei, die dann wieder
von kleinen Krebsen aufgenommen werden.
So also wird das Wasser neu verseucht - mit
der nächsten Generation von Larven. - ein
schlimmer Teufelskreislauf also!
Und genau da setzte der erste Ansatz der wirklich
groß angelegten Ausrottungskampagne an.
Die Menschen sind dazu aufgerufen, engmaschige
Stoffnetze zu benutzen.
Und so stand eigentlich der Plan, den Parasiten
bereits bis zum Jahr 2015 erfolgreich auszurotten.
Doch es kam anders als gedacht, denn der Wurm
war auf einen anderen Wirt ausgewichen: Hunde.
Wohl weil die Menschen schwieriger für ihn
zu erreichen waren.
Der genaue Hund-Mensch-Zyklus ist noch unklar
aber vermutet wird, dass sich die Hunde über
Fischabfälle infizieren und die Parasiten
dann an die Menschen weitergeben, indem sie
die Larven wieder ins Wasser bringen.
Ein fataler Rückschlag für die Ausrottungs-Pläne!
Deswegen wurde als ein zweiter wichtiger Schritt
den Fischern in betroffenen Regionen angeraten,
ihre Fischabfälle nicht weiter einfach wegzuwerfen,
sondern sicher zu entsorgen.
Und diese Maßnahmen scheinen wirklich zu
fruchten: 3,5 Millionen Neuinfektionen in
21 Ländern wurden Mitte der 80er Jahre registriert.
Der Grund: Schlechte sanitäre Versorgung
und fehlender Zugang zu sauberem Wasser. 2017
wurden noch 30 Fälle bekannt: jeweils die
Hälfte in Äthiopien und Tschad.
Und der Wurm quält uns Menschen übrigens
schon seit Jahrtausenden: Sogar in Mumien
wurden seine Spuren entdeckt!
Hauptverantwortlich für die Ausrottungs-Kampagne
ist übrigens das Carter-Center, das die Initiative
zur Bekämpfung des Guinea-Wurms 1986 gestartet
hat.
Die Non-Profit.Organisation wurde vom ehemaligen
US-Präsidenten Jimmy Carter und seiner Frau
gegründet.
Der krasse Rückgang der Infektionen ist eine
richtig gute Nachricht, denn es gibt keinerlei
Möglichkeiten, den Betroffenen zu helfen.
Dazu Donald Hopkins, ein Berater des Carter-Centers:
“Es gibt keine Impfung gegen den Parasiten
und keine wirksame Behandlung, daher konzentriert
sich die Kampagne darauf, sauberes Wasser
bereitzustellen und das Verhalten der Menschen
zu verändern.
Wie oben schon kurz angesprochen, lässt sich
der Wurm tatsächlich nur per Hand aus dem
Körper entfernen.
Die Menschen machen das meist selbst; ohne
medizinische Hilfe mit einem kleinen Stöckchen.
Dort wird ein kleines Stück des Wurms - etwa
zwei Zentimeter - Tag für Tag aufgerollt.
Wird da zu forsch herangegangen, reisst er
ab!
Ja, sind wir schon Zombies?
Lebewesen werden ferngesteuert durch Parasiten,
dafür hier drauf klicken.
Ein wirklich etwas beunruhigendes Video.
Ansonsten bis dann, bleibt dran.